carrusel de las artes
maría carolina piña
[Música]
carrusel de las artes se encuentra en el
festival de teatro más importante del
mundo el festival internacional de
aviñón para un número especial de
nuestro programa dedicado a las artes
escénicas
[Música]
en 2022 el festival internacional de
teatro de avignon reservó su escenario
más prestigioso al artista y disidente
ruso kirill serebrennikov quien presentó
el monje negro en el imponente palacio
de los papas avignon es el epicentro del
teatro mundial con más de 1500
espectáculos en toda la ciudad y uno en
especial habla de un viaje al centro del
mundo en ecuador conoceremos a los
artistas que la interpretan y en el año
del 400 aniversario de molière
regresamos a la ciudad medieval de penas
para conocer un poco más de la vida de
john but it's topo que lan antes de
convertirse en el dramaturgo del rey sol
y el padre del teatro francés
[Música]
nos encontramos en el patio de honor del
palacio de los papás el monumento más
importante de la ciudad que data del
siglo 14 cuando vino fue la sede del
catolicismo y es en este edificio
medieval que se abre tradicionalmente el
festival internacional de teatro con un
invitado de lujo este año el director
ruso kirill serebrennikov el festival de
aviñón abrió en 2022 con un relato sobre
la locura y la fragilidad humana el
monje negro de antón chéjov retumbo en
el palacio de los papás en esta versión
del director ruso kirill serebrennikov
la pieza narra la historia de andrés un
intelectual con los nervios de punta
atormentado por el fantasma de un monje
negro
el monje negro no habla solo de la
locura es una pieza que cuando la leí me
puso la piel de gallina el personaje
principal está frente a una situación
crítica que cualquiera podría vivir pero
lo que más me interesaba explorar es ese
momento en el que debemos tomar una
decisión crucial si aguantar o
abandonarnos a la locura
vistan de noche
kiril serebrennikov es todo un símbolo
en avignon director de teatro y de cine
pero también disidente encarcelado a
domicilio durante meses por vladimir
putin y ahora radicado en europa entre
arte y militancia y acertado mosto ya
trate y small creo que haya un teatro
político el teatro es la política misma
es el lugar donde hablamos de la
realidad donde expresamos nuestra
opinión y donde queremos creer que la
gente que viene a ver un espectáculo
sale de él distinta eso es en definitiva
la política dirigirse a un gran número
de personas y tratar de compensar los a
través de las ideas que creemos justas
en libertad plena adquirir serebrennikov
no desaprovecha ninguna ocasión en su
lucha contra el kremlin
el hecho queremos terminar la pieza aquí
en avignon haciendo un nuevo llamado a
parar la guerra en ucrania para eso
también es el teatro no podemos
olvidarnos de eso tenemos que seguir
denunciando
recordar a la gente que en estos
momentos en los que asistimos al teatro
hay gente muriendo bajo la goma
[Música]
la edición número 76 del festival de
teatro de avignon presenta una
programación con 40 piezas y puestas en
escena inéditas y allá encontramos una
tragedia griega escrita y modernizada
para el público del siglo 21 ifigenia es
desde la antigüedad un símbolo del amor
filial sacrificado en nombre del bien
común a que mandó a la tragedia de
ifigenia la hija del rey agamenón dada
en sacrificio en la guerra contra troya
ha sido recurrente en el teatro
conversiones de eurípides jacint o que
más recientemente el autor portugués
tiago rodríguez desempolvó este relato
transformando a las mujeres del coro y
efigenia en féminas que no aceptan la
locura bélica de los hombres la francesa
ante hong es la autora de esta nueva
puesta en escena son de suma magnífica
este texto es magnífico y a la vez
escalofriante esa joven mujer ifigenia
que al final dice no ella es la clave de
todo lo cambia todo sigue siendo una
tragedia pero con la posibilidad de otro
final
una tragedia siempre habla de un héroe
que debe escoger entre dos imposibles es
el caso de agamenón
las mujeres expresan claramente ellas no
quieren la guerra ni tampoco que los
hombres repitan las mismas acciones que
llevan a las mismas desgracias de
siempre ellas saben que hay otra opción
es lo que es estremecedor
posible es aquel verso
ante hong utiliza numerosos recursos
audiovisuales y una escenografía
depurada en la que el suelo se
resquebraja a medida que se cuenta la
historia que ofrecen o grafía es un
elemento sobre el cual se articula toda
la acción no es un decorado o algo que
busca copiar la realidad al contrario es
la base para que cada quien se imaginen
su propia historia los efectos sonoros
las imágenes todo convergen para crear
un universo completo que acompaña al
texto
tú quieres
en el reparto de esta ifigenia
presentada en avignon actores
portugueses que rinden homenaje al texto
original
[Música]
es una coproducción franco portuguesa y
trabajar con actores portugueses fue
fabuloso fuimos a oporto ensayamos con
ellos y trabajando me di cuenta que la
lengua portuguesa debía convertirse en
el idioma del amor ifigenia de aquiles
se enamoran inmediatamente a diferencia
de lo que sucede en la tragedia griega
es una buena primera vista y me pareció
lógico que se hablarán en portugués
taiana milonga
fandós
[Música]
aviñón es también el escenario del que
llaman el love es decir el festival
paralelo que comprende 1500 espectáculos
por toda la ciudad los artistas colocan
afiches por todas partes invitando al
público a venir al teatro y allí en el
festival of conocimos a una compañía que
nos habla de un viaje desde europa hasta
el centro de la tierra
[Música]
en diciembre de 1927 el joven poeta game
show se embarca en un viaje a ecuador un
periplo que el escritor describió en una
novela entre realidad y fantasía la
compañía internacional de una vía llevó
este texto ecuador a las tablas en una
puesta en escena cargada de música
este espíritu por su poder
[Música]
es un de carne de viaje del poeta belga
y francés o jimmy choo al principio del
siglo 20
era muy que tenía 29 años y se fue a
ecuador desde parís fue un encuentro un
viaje el viaje de mi show hasta el
ecuador pero también un viaje entre dos
culturas muy muy diferentes y fue un
encuentro muy rico
en el papel de este viajero que descubre
los andes' la selva y las enfermedades
tropicales el actor colombiano marlón
viscut rincón primero el encuentro con
el texto fue fue un descubrimiento total
yo no lo había leído antes no lo conocía
pero conozco de cierta manera el
territorio del que se habla en la obra
conozco mi familia viene de un
territorio que se comparte con el
ecuador en donde digamos que esta jungla
amazónica y este
este digamos este ambiente está muy
presente
[Música]
la obra se hace completamente en francés
solo hay una pequeña parte en español
que es la introducción a este universo
de latinoamérica la lengua francesa es
una lengua que exige una gimnasia pero
digamos que esa ese acento y eso es lo
que nos deja transmitirle también al
público este otro lado del mundo
para los dos artistas presentarse en el
festival de teatro más grande del mundo
ha sido una experiencia exigente para
nosotros entonces la primera vez que
venimos a baño como espectador también
es la primera vez que vengo a esta
ciudad entonces es todo un encuentro con
una con una jungla artística porque son
1500 espectáculos está la viña en el año
off muchos artistas mucha gente que
quiere ver teatro entonces de alguna
manera es un esto hace vivir realmente
hace vivir es fuerte porque hay que
buscar el público hay que salir a vender
nuestra obra pero de todas maneras
cuando la obra se hace cuando el público
sale de la sala eso es lo que realmente
paga el estar acá poder transmitir ese
texto
dejamos por un momento la efervescencia
de aviñón para ir a la ciudad de penas a
150 kilómetros de aquí para conocer un
poco más de la vida de molière el padre
del teatro francés cuando se cumplen 400
años de su natalicio y es que antes de
brillar en versalles con el rey sol
molía se desempeñó como dramaturgo y
animador personal del gobernador de la
región y es una historia que nos cuenta
medita barra
[Música]
antes de la fama y la gloria molière y
su compañía de teatro viajaron de ciudad
en ciudad por toda francia en el sur su
notoriedad empezó a crecer y en los años
1650 uno de los príncipes más poderosos
de francia le abrió las puertas de su
castillo una residencia llamada lagos de
pepe
[Música]
gubern
el príncipe de conti fue gobernador de
la región de la cndh ok esta era su
residencia principal a quien pese nas
organizó los estados generales las
asambleas políticas provinciales que
duraban varios meses a esos congresos
asistí a toda la nobleza de la región y
había que distraer la mujer vino varias
veces a la guste que actuó y entretuvo a
la corte con sus bromas fue si viera
prodigioso yo dije
[Música]
el príncipe de conti se convirtió en
mecenas y protector del joven dramaturgo
y molière permaneció semanas incluso
meses en el castillo
y lo imaginó caminando por estas sendas
como sería esa época con conciertos
música bailes comedias interludios todo
muy alegre
[Música]
otro edificio de personas aún guarda
vivo el espíritu del molière ismo tras
una puerta discreta del centro de la
ciudad se esconde un majestuoso palacete
que también pertenecía al gobernador se
cree que la primera representación del
médico volador fue en el patio de esta
residencia llamada hoy hotel de alphonse
molière
de la hoya se inspiró en una farsa de la
comedia dell'arte hay un personaje que
se hace pasar por alguien más actúa con
ubicuidad y hay una escena en la cual
debe estar en dos lugares a la vez él
está en la planta baja y debe encarnar a
un médico en el piso superior por lo que
se usaba un mecanismo de cuerdas y
poleas para trasladarlo al segundo piso
por eso se llama el médico volador
pelotita el médico volante
pocos años después la amistad que unió a
molière con el príncipe borbón se rompió
brutalmente
[Música]
al príncipe de contín un obispo lo
convirtió alcance mismo un movimiento
puritano muy austero y penitente que le
prohibía frecuentar actores cuando
molière se vio obligado a partir paso
bajo la protección del gran conde el
hermano de conti que rápidamente lo
llevó a louis 14 a versalles y a la
gloria
tras su partida el padre del teatro
francés guardó el recuerdo de sus años
en personas la ciudad que selló su
destino para siempre que él muriera no
moría se nutrió de todo lo que vio y
vivió en ese entorno de nobleza como su
objetivo era denunciar la hipocresía por
supuesto eso alimentó su teatro y su
imaginación sus obras reflejan lo que
fue el siglo 17
[Música]
gracias melisa barry con esto ponemos
punto final de este programa especial
dedicado a las artes escénicas que les
presentamos desde el festival
internacional de teatro de avignon
muchísimas gracias por su sintonía y
hasta la próxima jaua
[Música]